[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
salat rezept ist durch wahrscheinlich im
salat okay aber das ist ein besonderer
salat wir machen nämlich den originalton
um panel ist dallas das so von nus rap
muss red ist in der türkei extrem
bekannt mittlerweile auch weltweit ist
nämlich der hier der wird diese salz und
der hat eben auf seiner speisekarte
diesen salat und wir haben uns ein
bisschen zwei mal bestellt
wir waren zweimal istanbul und dann
haben wir uns den beide ware beliefern
zu den ja genau
ganz genau meine meinung ich fand den
auch sehr lecker aber ich bin kein fan
von ziegenkäse ich zeig euch hier
natürlich den salat mit ziegenkäse
könnte dabei auch schaafs kritischer bis
nehmen aber es kommt auch so ein
bisschen auf das drumherum an und vor
allem auf das dressing und ich zeige
euch jetzt was ich so da hab das wird
eher so ein lockeres video war ein
rezept ist streng genommen nicht ganz
sondern wir würfeln jetzt ganz viel
zusammen ich habe jetzt hier grün zeigt
also ganz normal salatblätter da könnt
ihr auch variieren und da gebe ich jetzt
direkt schon diese zutaten mit dazu ich
habe hier den apfel sehr fein
geschnitten dann habe ich hier
blaubeeren laut original sind übrigens
getrocknete blaubeeren aber die habe ich
nicht gefunden ich finde es auch nicht
so schlimm
es sind auf jeden fall frische
blaubeeren und cherry tomaten und die
gebe ich jetzt schon mal als allererstes
da rein
[Musik]
zum salat geben wir jetzt noch rosin
walnüsse und sojasprossen wenn ihr keine
sojasprossen her bekommt dann nehmt ihr
mungobohnenkeimlinge die sind so ein
bisschen saftiger und fleißiger die
könnt ihr auch nehmen und wenn ihr die
möglichkeit habt dann nimmt nicht die
aus dem glas sondern die frischen dann
ist es auch noch ein bisschen knackiger
so und jetzt gebe ich noch granatapfel
kerne mit dazu und das liebe ich so an
dem salat nicht nur die granatapfel
kerner also die gebe ich hier schon mal
mit da rein sondern auch später das
dressing das machen wir auch jetzt weil
ich gebe den käse ganz gerne ganz zum
schluss mit dazu
dann gehe ich einfach oben drauf und
jetzt zeige ich euch das dressing dafür
nehme ich mir so eine kleine schüssel
und da kommt dann granatapfel sirup rein
außerdem so ein bisschen zitronensaft
olivenöl und ein bisschen zeit und beim
granatapfel sirup ist es mir ganz
wichtig welchen ihr benutze ich völlig
selbstverständlich meinen in die infobox
unten
genauso wie alles was ich hier so
benutze und da ist es wichtig dass es
eben nicht so zusatzstoffe hat nicht so
unnötige zusatzstoffe und man merkt auch
jetzt wenn ich ihnen hier so in eine
schüssel rhein fließen lasse an der
konsistenz der ist eben nicht so
gestreckt sondern mache ich das dreßen
modell ist der salat eigentlich auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
geht der ernst das ist ein video kann
diese selbst die so stimmt ich musste
eigentlich so machen aber ich liebe man
salzstreuer wollte machen
ich hoffe dass er mich dafür nicht
verflucht so und jetzt ist eigentlich
das dressing auch schon fertig einfach
nur verrührt und am besten noch mal
selber abschmecken weil jeder mahlzeit
anders dauer und anders aus granatapfel
sirup hat er nochmal dieses süßliche ich
liebe das richtig lecker
[Musik]
ja und das war das rezept zum
berühmt-berüchtigten nuss tritt salat
mit dem tool um käse also mit dem
ziegenkäse und wenn ihr das ganze jetzt
nach machen möchte dann schaut in die
video beschreibung könnte sie als
inspiration nehmen und vielleicht auch
das dressing zu einem anderen salat
machen oder die zutaten austauschen
sowie ihr das mich wird jetzt auch mal
interessieren wart ihr schon mal beim
ausritt essen und wenn ja gefällt es
euch ist es das geld wert dieser salat
kostet zum beispiel ist nicht der das
ist ja echt viel
der kostet pro person 27 türkische lira
das sind ungefähr wie viel euro 4 euro
noch was für eur 15
und das für einen person also das ist
schon für türkische verhältnisse war ich
noch viel für deutschen jetzt nicht aber
er ist dennoch sehr sehr lecker also
ganz viel freude beim nachmachen wenn
ihr weitere nachgemachte rezepte haben
möchte dann schreibt mir das doch hier
unten rein welches versetzt euch
unbedingt nachmachen
ich muss immer vorher einmal probieren
ich mache mich zwar nicht probiert habe
aber das ist für mich auch eine coole
challenge ansonsten dem kanal ein
bäumchen nach oben da lassen diesem
video und den kanal abonnieren und dann
sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten
rezept
[Musik]